ήταν τόση μεγάλη τραγωδία αλλοι είχαν χασιανθώπους δικος τους αλλή είχαν χάσει τα πάντα φεύγοντας
από τα σπίτια τους που βεβαίως δ ήταν εύκολο να μπορέσεις να παρηγορήσεις κάποιον με
ε τέτοια κατάσταση αλλά πραγματικά είδα ότι μπορούσαμε να μπορούσαμε να ποσφεγουμε και επωσφερ πρόσφερε
πάρα πολύ ο ελθόστυος τομετά την μετά την ισβολή και οι κυριασουλιότι που τότι ήταν
υ πρόεδος του εγηλθούσταυγου οιδέκτικες υχαριτήρια οιια τον τπου που διαχειρίστηκε την όλη κατάσταση και
τις βοήθειες που έχουνταν από το εξωτερικό γι ότι εξέρετει σε τέτοιες καταστάσεις πολλές φορές
υπάρχουν καιοι βοήθειες μπορεί να να φύγουν και να μην πάνε εκεί που πρέπει να
ποιαίνουν και ι πραγματικά επεξεένα πολύ μεγαλολο ρόλον των οποίον είναι ακόμη πιο τεράστιος ρόλος
το εθρο σταύρού και σήμερα πως μιώθεται κυ ραβαβαδό πουλπου βλέπεται τον κόσμο ότι ανγκαλιάζει
το εργοτών ύθρο σταύρου και όλο και περισσότερος κόσμος είναι βίπλα σας έχουμε νομίζω τι
αποδείξαμε ότι όταν λέμε κάτι το κάνουμε είχαμε τελευταίως την περίπτωση με το κόβιτοπου εμβοηθείθαμε
περίπρονη είναι τα χιλιάδες κόσμο μέσα στο κόβι ε με τον κόσμο που μας τηλεφωνούςχρειάζουνταν
βοήθεια επι ένα μεκατικον επισκέψεις αφήναμε τότε ακόμα δεν ξέγμε καλά καλά για τον κόμητοόπως
ξέρεται και σεις αφήναμε ταότι εχρειάζετουν επιγαίνανεψουνίζαν τον κόσμο επίένα στο νοσοκομείο να πάγουν βοηθεήματα
και ο ξηγόνο και διάφογα λλα και φάγμακα που χρειάζουνταν κάποιο ανθρώπι που δεν μπορούσαν
να βγουν από το σπίτι τους και νομίζω ότι απαιδείξαμε ότι μποούμε να βοηθήσουμε καιάρχει
κάποιον περιστατικό σε όλη να αυτή